Bloomberg smacked Bernie Warren's
scalped Bloomberg and Joe Biden wrecked
himself we will examine the highlights
from the wildest 2020 Democratic debates
so far and specifically how Mike
Bloomberg fundamentally misunderstands
the presidency then AOC wants
billionaires to disappear and the
moralists of modernity at Slate Magazine
can't quite explain why it's wrong to
sleep with your brother all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael an old show
[Music]
whoo boy is there a lot to get to Mike
Bloomberg finally makes the democratic
debates interesting sparks flew this was
a brutal brutal debate we saw firsthand
because of this debate pretty much
everything that's wrong with modernity I
mean it was the it was the most broad
overview of everything that's gone wrong
with the Democrats with liberalism with
leftism with modernity we'll get to all
that in a second first got to thank our
friends over at fairway meat market oh
how I love fairway meat market fairway
is a family-owned grocery chain that has
been in business since 1938 fairways
premium beef and all-natural pork is
raised by family farmers and hand cut by
a highly experienced team of fairway
butchers from ribs to rib eyes pork
chops to beef tenderloin all at fairway
meat market calm I love fairway I
discovered them I was coming back from a
long trip and they had sent me all of
this meat and that meat is so so good I
love it
these guys are the real deal and you
you're gonna love them too how would you
like to get a deal on fairways heartland
package this one I would highly
recommend personally that includes eight
8-ounce all-natural boneless pork chops
six eight ounce USDA choice ribeye
steaks one mouth-watering side dish
which could be loaded baked potato
gourmet cheesy corn or brisket baked
beans this week my listeners can get the
Heartland package valued at $230 for
just $99.99 go do it do not miss out on
this plus you get free shipping when you
enter Noel's ko wles at checkout that's
more than 50% off the best meat in
America plus free shipping that's
fairway meat market calm promo code
Knolls canna wles
and I would personally recommend look
for the heartland package alright what a
crazy debate everybody came out of this
debate looking terrible the radicals the
Liberals the billionaires that everybody
looked terrible but especially
especially Mike Bloomberg and this was
to be expected this started right out
the door of the debate Mike Bloomberg
shows up everybody is
going after him and Bloomberg simply
wasn't prepared so Warren kicked it all
off by attempting she later completed
this but she attempted to just
absolutely end
Bloomberg's campaign before it began I'd
like to talk about who were running
against a billionaire who calls women
fat broads and horseface lesbians and no
I'm not talking about Donald Trump
I'm talking about Mayor Bloomberg are
not going to win if we have a nominee
who has a history of hiding his tax
returns of harassing women and of
supporting racist policies like
redlining
and stop and frisk all right Bloomberg's
team completely blew this if they did
not prepare him for this question this
was obviously going to be a big question
because it's very difficult to attack
Mike Bloomberg he's had an extremely
successful career he's a Democrat so he
holds most of the current politically
correct political positions but because
he runs any large enterprise there are
these NDA's and they're you know
obviously there's always HR issues so
they're gonna try to portray Mike
Bloomberg who's a very good manager of
these enterprises as some kind of sexual
predator because what cuz he made a joke
20 years ago or something Bloomberg
should have seen that coming
his team didn't prep him no surprise
that the geniuses who thought that a
campaign strategy was putting
Bloomberg's face on a meat ball on
social media that that that somehow they
would botch debate prep but what's so
crazy about that moment is Bloomberg
could have seen it coming because it's
the exact moment that happened to Trump
in his debate four years ago and you
remember that first debate Trump comes
out there everyone's gunning for Trump
and they tried to hit him on the same
thing they said you've made mean jokes
about women and megyn kelly was the
moderator and she said mr. president
must not be wasn't president then he
said mr. Trump you've called women fat
and ugly and terrible and instead of
doing what my Bloomberg did which was
wilt and don't say anything and then you
say I'm sorry
Trump leaned right into it you've called
women you don't like fat pigs dogs slobs
and disgusting animals
your Twitter account only Rosie
O'Donnell one of the most memorable
lines in presidential debates and I
remember watching it in real time in
2016 and thinking oh man this guy's
really got something this guy is not
going to be pushed around this guy
understands how to play the media and
Bloomberg blew it now Bloomberg couldn't
have used the exact same line he
couldn't they couldn't have said you
Mike Bloomberg you've called women
horseface lesbians and then Bloomberg
leans in says only Suze in accounting
yeah right that that obviously isn't
going to work
but he could have gotten aggressive okay
if this is gonna be the line of attack
on brash New York billionaires which is
that they make off-color jokes he could
have leaned into it and gone on the
attack and been even more brash and said
you know Elizabeth you're one of the
most notorious liars in the country you
lied about your DNA for decades and took
jobs away from Native Americans you lied
about where your kids go to school you
lied about being fired for being
pregnant so excuse me if I don't take
you seriously
I shouldn't be surprised that you would
lie about me too if he just leaned in
and made it an attack I think people
would have stood up and and loved him
for it you know nobody wants this awful
lying dishonest woman to Hector some guy
who's had a very successful career in
business that doesn't look good to most
Americans but if she's gonna be able to
push him around then she's gonna win the
exchange which is exactly what happened
on the issues not the style necessarily
but the issues Bloomberg was actually
pretty good I mean this was by far the
best he did all night he got some pretty
good zingers in at Bernie Sanders and
Bernie was really going after him for
being a billionaire now you remember
Bernie Sanders used to go after the
millionaires and billionaires but then
Bernie made over a million dollars so
all of a sudden the millionaires were
okay and it was only the billionaires I
mean Bernie Sanders a total fraud and
Mike Bloomberg called him out for it he
had one of the great lines of the night
he said what a great country we live in
that the most famous socialist in the
country is a millionaire with three
houses
country the best known socialists in the
country happens to be a millionaire with
three houses what I miss here
well you'll this that I've worked in
Washington house watch the first problem
live in Burlington house - that's good
and like thousands of other for Martha's
I do all the supper cap for that is your
home which talks which tax haven New
York cities thank you very much oh my
gosh absolutely a devastating response
because bernie is an obvious fraud okay
he is a multi-millionaire right he's got
all these houses and yet he's claims to
be a man of the people and a socialist
this is a guy who's hasn't done any
productive work in his entire life he
was a vagrant who got kicked off of a
commune then he realized that his best
chance at success was working in
government and then he did that for the
rest of his life and then he whined and
complained II didn't accomplish anything
there in in government itself so
Bloomberg goes that he goes yeah Bernie
you're a complete fraud and you're a
millionaire and you have multiple houses
and Bernie had no answer for that but he
said okay well yeah I work in Washington
it been Bloomberg he's got that New York
that dry just hits he goes yeah that's
the first problem he goes and Bloomberg
didn't have an answer or Bernie rather
didn't have an answer for his third home
because it's a summer home he goes well
I have a summer home like you know so
many Americans do so many Americans have
summer homes that was news to me I guess
I got to become one of those so many
Americans because I sure would love a
summer home so he really gets that zing
in there and even then he tries to
deflect it by hitting Bloomberg on
having a tax haven but Bloomberg doesn't
live in a tax haven he lives in New York
and pays extremely high taxes so that
was a great line a speaking of taxes
there was a wonderful exchange where
Bernie said you know the billionaire's
pay lower taxes than the middle class
which is simply not true but Bloomberg
actually got a great line of attack and
he leans in and he says Bernie who
writes the tax code right Bloomberg's
just runs a business Bernie Sanders is a
senator it's the it's the politicians
who write the tax code right so then
Bernie tries to flip eases the bill
is right I mean the politicians at the
behest of the billionaires right the tax
code so Bernie's admitting that the
politicians are all bought off but then
the the punch line was Bloomberg leans
in there he says Bernie most
billionaires are Democrats and they are
it's true I think of the ten richest
people in the country seven of them are
Democrats there are two billionaires in
the Democratic presidential primary
right now Mike Bloomberg and Tom Steyer
all the most famous billionaires we can
think of Warren Buffett Bill Gates
Zuckerberg right they all are leaning
left with Mike Bloomberg they all lean
left they're virtually all Democrats so
these were all great really good hits
then Bloomberg moves on from those good
zingers and shows the radicalism of the
Democratic Party because he says look
guys we're not going to destroy
capitalism we're not going to all of a
sudden become communist communism
doesn't work and do you know what
happened when Bloomberg said communism
doesn't work he got booed by the
audience and by the other candidates I
can't think of a ways that would make it
easier for Donald Trump to get
re-elected than listening to this
conversation
[Applause]
we tried that all the countries tried
bad what's called communism and it just
didn't work oh hold on a sec you're
gonna go after communism now hold on no
I don't know about that guys you see
Elizabeth Warren it like pains her when
he says communism just didn't work she
goes well hold on you look at Bernie it
looks like he's about to collapse what
do you mean communism doesn't work so
it's a wild moment because five years
ago even five five six years ago if you
had told me that a democratic debate
would mention communism and an attack on
communism would get booed I'd say no
that's crazy that's too radical even for
them I mean consider the fact just in
the Bloomberg questioning the Democrats
went wild for an attack over a sex joke
but they booed an attack on communism
Liz Warren goes after blue
because he made a joke about women like
once and wild applause and then
Bloomberg said hey guys I think
communism is bad and boos from the
audience and from the other candidates
but Bloomberg was not deterred he
tripled down on economic freedom they
were good issue points but then he
totally blew it in the end we'll get to
that in a second first got to thank our
friends over it to Kovas to Kovas cowboy
boots they're handmade they have high
quality full grain leather x' by
world-class boot makers and they just
look great they look really really cool
even a city slicker like me can wear two
Kovas and I know you can to them they're
just a really beautiful product and my
favorite part of it is they are built to
be comfortable right out of the box all
right I'm not exactly wrangling cattle
over here in the middle of Los Angeles
sometimes sometimes it kind of feels
that way you're sitting in LA traffic
you don't need to break them in you
don't they're just comfortable
immediately you can wear them to the
office you wear them at home you know
where I'm on the town they've got tons
of timeless styles they're designed to
be fashionable 50 years from now just as
fashionable as they are today and
because to Kovas cuts out the middleman
they sell direct to you with a great
price do what I did get yourself a pair
of two Kovas cowboy boots today at two
Kovas comm slash knowles KO wles that is
tec ova s.com slash Noel's canna wles
Tuco viscom slash Noel's so Bloomberg
triples down on this right he is not
going to get rid of economic freedom
he's not going to get rid of capitalism
he's asked at one point by a moderator
this is pretty amazing do you think that
you should have made all that money that
you made as I love when people feel
they're entitled to everybody else's
stuff and that somehow virtuous that the
vise of envy is now somehow a virtue on
the left but that's the question let's
ask do you think you should have made
all that money and Bloomberg says you're
damn right I should have did you exist
for all billion is all I know is I've
been very lucky made a lot of money and
I'm giving it all away to make this
country better and the good chunk of it
goes to the Democratic Party as well
[Applause]
been an obscene amount of should you
have earned that much money yes I worked
very hard for a great answer I love to
Bloomberg s to cachi is like by the way
I I am using a lot of my money to bribe
the Democratic Party don't forget it's
not just that I'm making it and
stimulating the economy and donating to
charity I'm also bribing your party so
you know that's okay that's the only
reason I'm in the debate right now is
because I made a three hundred thousand
dollar donation to the Democrats right
before I got in the race so just want to
let you know I'm using my money wisely
obviously a little little grift and
cronyism going on here and the Democrats
but he makes a very good point he goes
I've worked very hard and I'm giving all
my money away think about how much money
Mike Bloomberg gives to charity he's one
of the most philanthropic men in the
country how much money do you give to
charity
how much money does Chuck Todd give to
charity how much money do any of the
Democrats on stage Bernie Sanders oh my
god I don't know that guy ever gave to
charity it's pretty pretty to low amount
according to his tax returns so I like
that he tripled down on that I thought
Bloomberg made some good issue points
his his style was not terribly effective
I got a kick out of it as a New Yorker
but wasn't very effective overall the
debate was a loser for Bloomberg it was
it was a big loser and the reason is he
didn't accomplish the one thing that he
was supposed to accomplish at this
debate
he didn't connect with voters he did
that's the why else would he have shown
up to this debate
he was already buying the primaries is
his numbers were surging even though he
had never appeared on a stage right he
was just buying a ton of airtime spent
like half a billion dollars or something
why show up and open yourself up to all
of these attacks which he got the only
reason to do it is to connect with
voters to show you're not afraid to show
that you got something here he didn't do
that if anything he distanced himself
from voters
nowhere is that clearer than in his
response to a challenge one of these
dumb political challenges they say are
you going to release your tax returns
now I don't think politicians are
obligated to release their tax returns
and actually in the post Trump era I
don't know that they will be required to
but it's one of these old lines and they
especially use it against businessmen
because the tax returns of politicians
are very easy because they don't work in
the productive economy whereas the tax
returns a businessmen are very
complicated and so there's a lot to pick
apart and use in attack ads and
Bloomberg says look ok I'll release my
tax returns but I'm a billionaire with
businesses all around the world it's not
so easy but he gave an answer that
seemed pretty condescending and a little
offensive to the regular old American
voter you would eventually release your
tax records yes it comes to transparency
but people are already voting now why
should democratic voters have to wait
it just takes us a long time to
unfortunately or fortunately fortunately
I make a lot of money and we do business
all around the world and we are
preparing it in the number of pages will
probably be thousands of pages I can't
go to TurboTax I got to tell you I
actually really liked this line I
thought it was pretty funny because it's
such an obvious point it's like look
guys I I know you think that releasing
my taxes is like I click print on my
computer but I'm Michael Bloomberg okay
I've got a ton of business interests
everywhere this will be thousands of
pages long and yeah you can't you can't
go to TurboTax right you can't walk to
H&R Block and have them prepare your
taxes a very funny line but it's it
seems a little sneering - right so it's
funny like for a stand-up and it's funny
if you have a connection to voters it's
fun I think Trump could have gotten away
with that line because Trump has this
connection to voters you have the real
sense that Trump really likes his voters
he really likes his supporters he really
likes this countrymen right you don't
get that sense with Bloomberg and so
with Bloomberg it just emphasizes it
underlines the the major weakness of his
campaign which is that he seems like
this
who doesn't like people who doesn't care
about people who doesn't doesn't want to
be listening to their concerns so I'm I
can't go to turbo texts like you little
people like you peasants
I'm Michael Bloomberg so he took a line
that could have been pretty funny and
and just blew it because of his attitude
then he blew it worst of all this was
the moment nobody is talking about this
but I actually think it was the worst
moment of the entire debate for
Bloomberg and I didn't see anybody
really mention it on Twitter in his
close a statement Mike Bloomberg finally
makes the case for why you should elect
him and he revealed that he
fundamentally misunderstands the
American presidency he said his big case
for why you should elect him is that the
presidency is a management job and he's
a good manager this is a management job
and Donald Trump's not a manager this is
a job we have to build teams he doesn't
have a team so he goes and makes
decisions without knowing what's going
on at the implications of what he does
we cannot run the railroad this way this
is so wrong this is so incorrect the
presidency is not a management job
primarily obviously there's a little bit
of managing going on I guess there's a
little bit of managing that goes on in
most jobs but the the presidency is not
primarily a management job and it just
reveals why nobody really supports what
Bloomberg thinks not the left not the
right
probably not even the center Mike
Bloomberg is a neoliberal technocrat
that would be the precise term for him
he looks at all the political problems
of the world and he doesn't think of
them in terms of great ideas or
philosophy or the theological basis of
those ideas or what moves and stirs the
human soul he thinks about them from the
perspective of getting a little more
efficiency out of the market of just
putting a few experts in there and if
they're smart enough and they got more
gray matter like Bloomberg said the
other day then they'll be able to get a
little more money out of the economy and
then everybody will go along because
we've got this perfect technical
vision of the world and that's not how
the world works but that's that's how my
Klum burgers always thought of politics
when Mike Bloomberg ran for mayor of New
York he said we can't have more than two
terms for mayor then he becomes mayor he
says all right we're in at a third term
why because I'm the expert I'm Mike
Bloomberg I can do whatever I want
rules don't apply to me then he gets the
third term and he takes away the third
term for everybody else he finally gets
booted out of power in New York and do
you know what his the next job was that
he wanted it wasn't president right away
he considered becoming mayor of London
there was a real push for Mike Bloomberg
the former mayor of New York to become
the mayor of London that's so weird
right he's not English he didn't live in
England why would he be cut because -
Mike Bloomberg running these cities it's
all the same it's all cookie cutter you
just have to get the right technical
systems in place and you know build
teams and have have good retreats and
then implement these good PowerPoint
strategies and models and then the city
will run the right way and it has
nothing to do with the ideas that lead
politics it has nothing to do with
actually accomplishing something in
politics beyond efficiency it has
nothing to do with the people right -
Mike Bloomberg yeah okay New Yorkers
Englishmen Londoners whoever any you can
substitute any people it doesn't matter
but of course people are the most
important thing in politics politics is
how we people all get along in society
and Bloomberg just just fundamentally
doesn't get it our framers did not think
that the presidency was a management job
our founders and framers thought that
the presidency was the spirited part of
the government this is where some people
on the right get it wrong - some people
on the right say ah the president he's
just a regular bureaucrat just like
anybody else no he isn't
the government the presidency rather as
the framers intended is not just some
random bean counter he's not just some
random bureaucrat he's the spirit the
embodiment of the spirit of the
government when the framers set up our
governments in three parts right the
judiciary the legislature and the
executive those three parts are designed
to correspond to the three parts of the
human soul there
designed to correspond in the judiciary
that corresponds to the logical part of
the soul the legislature responds to the
emotional part of the soul and the
executive responds to the spirited part
of the soul in Greek would be the logos
the pathos and the ethos but it's the
say it's the three divisions of the soul
of three divisions of government they
work very well but it's about the soul
it's about people it's about great
forces that move us not just making some
plastic goods a little bit cheaper and
markets a little bit more efficient
that's why Bloomberg doesn't get it and
that's why very likely even beyond all
the other attacks on them all night that
is why very likely he's not going
anywhere the other candidates are all
Joker's too we've got to get to a OC by
the way being the the future of the
Democratic Party and we've got to get to
why Slate Magazine doesn't understand
that a sister should not have sex with
her brother we'll get to all of that
plus the mailbag first got to thank our
friends over at Rock Auto I love rock
Auto you know I love rock Auto I love it
because it's a family business I also
love it because it's so much better then
all those chains do you know chain
stores have different price tiers for
professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers rockauto.com doesn't
even require membership or an account
login I love that because when my car
breaks down I go to the chain store I go
to the physical shop right and all they
they never have the part they just go
online and they order the part probably
from Rock Auto and then they charge me a
huge markup and I don't know and it's
very opaque and it's very hard to see
what's going on not with rock Auto Rock
Auto gives you fair prices all the time
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
and even new carpet whatever car
whatever truck it's for you can get
everything in a few easy clicks even I
can understand the website go to Rock
Auto calm right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
Knowles can or wles and there how did
you hear about us box and then they will
know that we sent you rockauto.com okay
all the other candidates were Joker's
that's no surprise at all
the winner was Bernie Bernie won Warren
did pretty well too but that's only
because the moderators refused to go
after her weaknesses
moderators have gone after every other
candidate they haven't gone after Warren
they've gone after Budaj edge on race
they've gone after Sanders on his
alleged statement that women can't be
President he went they went after
Bloomberg obviously on everything they
went after Amy for forgetting the name
of a foreign leader but they don't go
after Warren why Warren is the mo is the
weakest of the candidates she lied about
being a Native American for her whole
career probably took a job away from an
actual Native American she's lily-white
then lied about her kids school then
lied about getting fired for being
pregnant then just a lies lies lies but
they won't go after her and I think the
reason they won't go after her for the
Indian thing is because it looks like a
Trump attack it's an attack that Trump
is now totally owned they don't want to
be accused of playing into a trump
attack they don't want to be accused of
being harsh on women they don't want to
be accused of any of that so they they
just go they go easy on her and even
with all of that she's still not doing
very well in the polls all radical
candidates on that stage last night with
maybe the sort of exception of Mike
Bloomberg who got clobbered what this
shows us is that someone like AOC who
the DNC chairman Tom Perez said last
year or two years ago was the future of
the Democratic Party it shows that she's
not just some strange outlier or some
exception she really really is the
future of that party Wow all the
candidates were debating on stage with
Bloomberg aoc went on the view to
actually serve up one of the questions
from the debate AOC went on the view one
of the questions from the debate from
Chuck Todd was hey Mike Bloomberg should
you exist
that was from AOC who said explicitly on
the view billionaires right there are
fellow countryman citizens of America
should not exist here's the thing is
that if you it's the amount of money
that you have can force the DNC to
change their rules but the DNC would not
change their rules for Cory Booker who
Leon Castro Kamala Harris that is a that
is an actualization of power and we all
know how I feel about billionaires I
don't think that in a place where 60% of
Americans can't even you know make more
than $40,000 a year
the presence of a billionaire who
largely makes their money off of
businesses under paying their workers
like Walmart like Amazon like so on
should event billionaires should not
exist they shouldn't exist now when you
couple that with what we're hearing from
the rest of the Democrats the activists
in the field guys like one of Bernie
Sanders current campaign workers who
said that after the revolution they're
gonna line up all the bourgeois and sent
him to the gulag they're gonna line them
up on the wall and kill him that's like
actually what a campaign worker for
Bernie said and you hear this kind of
language gets you a little worried
because every radical socialist
communist regime in history has has had
to liquidate classes of people liquidate
is another word for murder they've had
to purge people that had to crack a few
eggs to make an omelet so that kind of
language and say is not great and you're
hearing it from the young fresh face of
the party
AOC not a good sign not a good sign for
the country the one glimmer of hope
however is that AOC is a hypocrite and
AOC revealed that in the same interview
with the view because she castigated all
those rich men and yet right now she's
campaigning for a rich man our entire
political system revolves frankly around
rich men and rich men are not the center
of my universe working families are yeah
okay I see well what's interesting is a
Oh see the reason she hasn't been doing
her job lately is because she's on the
campaign trail for Bernie Sanders who is
a very rich man he's an old rich man
that's like three strikes against him so
that is a lie I mean which is what she's
trying to say Oh men rich men they're
not the center of my universe working
families are al C doesn't answer the
phone in her district office for those
working families but she does spend a
lot of time on the campaign trail for
for Bernie Sanders that's a little
glimmer of hope however if we've if the
best hope we've got is Democrats
hypocrisy yeah I mean that's something
we can rely on but it doesn't say very
much about the Democratic Party before
we get to
the mailbag I've got to talk about the
grossest the grossest article this was
in Slate it was a letter written into
Slate Magazine it's called my wife wants
us to have sex with her brother
not just that she wants to have sex with
her brother but she wants them at both -
here's the letter dear had to do it my
wife and I have been in an open marriage
for five years so they're cheating on
each other they sleep with other people
on the whole our relationship has been
uncommon ly open and supportive
definitely uncommonly open we both
strive to encourage one another to
explore and even playfully push the
limits romantically and sexually for as
long as I've known her my wife has been
interested in incest role play okay well
it isn't my cup of tea exactly I've been
willing and happy to support her in her
exploration of this kind of fantasy and
roleplay often she will have me dress up
as her father wear his Cologne etc while
she will wear her high school clothes
okay
recently though things have started to
move in an uncomfortable direction
recently not before that all that other
stuff was comfortable wearing your dad's
Cologne totally normal but now it's
moving in an uncomfortable direction my
wife is very close with her older
brother who's also by bisexual and with
whom we often speak very openly about
sex and sexuality few nights ago and
after a few drinks my wife got to
talking fairly explicitly about some of
the family role-playing that she and I
are into and her brother who I thought
would be kind of horrified was not only
entirely supportive but vaguely
expressed interest in exploring this
kink with us exploring this kink by the
way is a euphemism for having sex when I
got when we got home I expected my wife
to make it clear that her brother ever
joining us in the bedroom was entirely
off the table but instead she seemed to
think it was a really good idea in
principle I don't have a problem with
this idea
we've got a pause here for a second if
in principle you don't have a problem
with you and your wife having sex with
her brother you probably don't have very
many principles you were probably not a
very principled person if that is in
principle you don't have a problem my
wife and I have also enjoyed group sex
orgies and so that isn't the problem
either I'm just worried about how this
could have
affect my relationship with my
brother-in-law is there a way for me to
make this happen without it getting
weird it's weird it's weird
buddy slate doesn't have much of an
answer to it the the advice columnist to
respond says swell look if you're
worried about how it's going to affect
your relationship with your brother then
don't do it basically right that's all
it said doesn't doesn't explain in
principle why this is a bad idea
so you'll notice what he says right he
says I'm kind of uncomfortable this this
is a little weird
and then he refers to the family
role-playing that he and she are into
but he just said he's not really into it
he's just doing it to humor her right he
said it's not my cup of tea but then he
says I'm into it so he's obviously not
the manliest man in the world he's
obviously getting pushed around quite
quite a lot here all of the reasoning
for why not to sleep with your wife's
brother is very it's just very
subjective it's very well if it'll
affect your relationship well if it'll
make family dinners awkward well if
it'll make family dinner as sexual well
if it you know Kay might just
situationally it might not work out
great
the reason not to have sex with your
wife and her brother at the same time is
because it's wrong it is morally wrong
it is objectively wrong wicked not just
a little bit creepy it's actually wrong
to do it it's a violation of the moral
order on top of all the other gross
aspects of it but we're not allowed to
say that anymore because we're not
allowed to say in this modern cult
sexually liberated culture of anything
goes and if it feels good do it we're
not allowed to say that certain sexual
acts are intrinsically disordered this
gets to the big debate that's been going
on on the right for months now it
started with the porn thing should we
regulate porn and you had the kind of
libertarian leaning people on the right
say no way if it doesn't hurt anybody
doesn't matter if it feels good do it
and then you had the conservatives say
no it this is pretty bad it's an
epidemic it's causing huge rises in edie
it's causing men to become perverted
it's a big problem in the country and we
don't want perverts running our country
there is no there is no violation of the
moral order that doesn't affect anybody
right there is no victimless crime as
they say all crimes have victims even if
you're the victim and the effects on
other people are difficult to measure
but they can be measured like for
instance if I become a drug addict and
kill myself
god forbid you could say that's a
victimless crime in that it's only
affecting me but of course it affects
many more people than you affects your
family it affects your friends it
affects your community that that is just
what happens with these violations of
the moral order you see it in in Utah
right now Utah just passed a bill to
legalize polygamy polygamy much much
more understandable than having sex with
your wife and a brother at the same time
but still a violation of our social and
sexual mores today in the fitt feels
good do it culture why is polygamy wrong
by the logic of obergefell there's a
decision that redefined marriage to
include monogamous same-sex unions by
the logic of that Supreme Court decision
which discovered somewhere in the
Constitution a right to intimacy not
sure where that was but between the
Articles I think by the logic of it why
should marriage not be redefined again
to include polygamy love is love if it
feels good do it it's not hurting
anybody it's a victimless crime right
and yet we all know yeah there's
something wrong about that there's
something wrong there we all know
there's something wrong about sleeping
with your wife and a brother at the same
time but we've convinced ourselves in
this very narrow rationalistic way this
shallow way that we cannot take
seriously moral discussion moral
disagreement it all just has to be about
us well it doesn't really hurt me it
doesn't really affect me that's not a
mature moral discussion it's not the
discussion that our framers had it's not
the discussion that any of our ancestors
had who built this great civilization
and if we don't start having that
discussion again we're not going to have
the civilization for very long okay we
got to get to the mailbag running late
as usual I want to bring your attention
to a possibly overlooked but a highly
valued daily wire membership tier that
is the readers pass a readers pass gets
you the articles ad
including Ben Shapiro's op-eds which are
exclusive for daily wire Members Only
you also get access to our mobile app to
read all of our stories and receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content perfect when you want to
stay up to date on the go
this Membership tier is already a
bargain at 3 bucks a month but if you
are still a little doubtful if you're
not a billionaire like my Bloomberg or a
millionaire like Bernie Sanders listen
to this offer right now you get one
month for 99 cents 99 cents that's
mobile ad free access to all of the
daily wire news exclusive op-eds from
ben shapiro
and breaking news and updates on our
mobile app all for the low price of one
dollar so go check it out you will not
be disappointed daily wire.com we'll be
right back with the mailbag
right back with the mailbag dear master
of cough FA a rend resident papist of
The Daily wire I am a conservative and a
Christian and I believe in the
differences of the sexes and that God
made us to be different and to suit
different roles
I don't accept the nonsense put forward
by the left that gender is separate from
sex however I experience gender
dysphoria I know that this is a
psychological problem and that I need to
solve it but any therapist I approach
will only give me affirmation therapy
and I'm ashamed to approach my family
friends or religious leaders and so I
come to you a social and political
commentator who I only know on the
Internet what would you advise I do
sincerely and may God bless you and
yours okay I'm very sorry to hear that
you're going through that it's very
tough affliction particularly because we
don't know exactly how to treat it first
of all I would I would correct you a
little bit here when you say you've got
to solve it you'd be nice if you could
solve it it'd be nice if you could get
rid of it but that's not the way that
afflictions always work sometimes we
just kind of bear suffering and
suffering sanctifies us spiritually but
it also shapes our character it also
deepens our understanding of the world
everybody suffers so you are not alone
in suffering though you do do have this
particular affliction you also have this
problem which is we live in a really
dumb society right now where any
psychologist you go to is not going to
give you a good psychological advice so
here here is my advice first of all a
little bit of encouragement I don't know
how old you are but when this gender
dysphoria occurs especially in young
people statistically for the majority of
people it will go away over time huge I
mean 80 to 90% of teenagers who
experience gender dysphoria it just kind
of goes away so that bit of advice could
just be try to bear it out and hope that
it goes away because statistically it
very possibly will the next thing you
should do you say you're afraid to talk
to your family about it I don't know
your family situation that might be
totally justified you don't want to talk
to therapists because a lot of them are
quacks totally true you're afraid of
talking to your religious leaders I
don't know who your religious
leaders are what I would recommend is
you talk to my religious leaders and
that's because the Catholic Church has a
nuanced view of this they've been
dealing with even think the Catholic
Church as with most things has been
thinking about it for 2,000 years so
there there is a kind of nuanced view
and I think you would probably get
pretty good balanced advice even on what
sort of psychologists to go seek out so
I would recommend you talk to a Catholic
priest about it even if you are not
Catholic yourself I just think you're
more likely and with various other
Protestant denominations it might be
more hit or miss just because there's so
many different doctrines that are out
there you know I know I don't want to
send you to the the wrong people even if
they're there could be some good ones
out there as well I would do that and
then I would do your best I'm actually
on the Catholic point I would recommend
finding a Catholic psychologist or at
least I say Catholic psychologist
because Catholic psychologists will
accept the natural law so they won't
push some wacky gender gnostic ideology
on you but if you find any psychologist
who recognizes them the natural law then
I think you'll be in a good place in the
meantime what you should do is not lose
heart be encouraged everybody is
suffering you've got this particular
affliction there are people out there
who you can speak to about this there
are people who are living with gender
dysphoria who are or who regret going
through sex affirmation surgery so I've
interviewed one of them now I forget his
name Peter something when I was
guest-hosting Ben's radio showing a Walt
hire talks about this a lot he's another
person who has gone back and he
regretted his surgery those those kind
of voices are out there as well and I
would recommend just given my own
knowledge of these religious leaders I
would recommend talking to a priest
about it just seeing even if they don't
give you religious advice that you like
if they can lead you to psychological
vice because there there are resources
out there and the best of luck I will
pray for you my friend from Grant hi
Michael I find a choir member in the
church extremely attractive and she
seems exceptionally sweet and genuine I
want to ask her out but have no idea how
to approach that any tips on asking her
out
what could my opening line be I've never
talked to her before but she has noticed
me a couple times I'm extremely nervous
and don't want to botch this thank you
for any advice yes I do have advice how
about you open with a compliment
this is now in our kind of ironic
culture we the idea of complimenting
somebody is unthinkable but how about
you try that a real compliment not
flattery people hate flattery but
actually you know hey as a lovely
cantata you sang oh I really love this
hymn
good choice those sort of things right
and make it genuine Oh lovely dress
I mean you know it could be as simple as
that and probably because men don't
understand how to talk to women very
much any more she will like that
especially if she's been noticing you
that's that she's probably looking for
an opportunity to talk to you as well
and then you can start a conversation
and if you open with a compliment it
allows you to take the conversation
somewhere that has some mutual interest
so if you say oh I really loved how you
sang how great thou art that him that
you were singing oh thank you so great
thou art yeah it's really good then you
can start talking about hymns and then
you'll have some common interest there I
assume if you're both in the church
choir and then you can bring it to the
place where I'm sure you want to bring
it to which is Oh what we we certainly
should discuss this further do you wanna
get a drink after after choir practice
or you want to go to dinner or after you
want to grab a coffee or something
that's where I would begin people always
ask how do I pick up a girl and the
answer is so simple that people over
look at which is be genuinely interested
in them be curious about what they have
to say like them they want to be around
them and I think you'll probably have a
good shot because it sounds to me like
she's interested as well okay from John
Deere dr. Kofi Fay / mr. small well
thank you for using both of my name's
winner of the Iowa caucus good thank you
for using my title given Trump has been
using the pardon power this week I
decided to refresh myself on the reasons
for the pardon power and find myself
unsatisfied by James Madison's rationale
that the executive has the power to
check the criminal justice system when
it goes awry it seems to be generally
abused by presidents Trump has used it
relatively sparingly if you have
your druthers would you erase the pardon
power altogether huge fan of the show
and your literary work thank you very
much I would not I love the pardon power
I think it's great I think the founders
and framers were smart to put it in the
Constitution because it humanizes
the government and after all what is our
government it's our fellow humans
governing us so obviously we're a nation
of laws not a nation of men we have this
justice but justice without love justice
without mercy is tyranny it's brittle it
will crack and so you need a little
safety valve in there and that safety
valve is the pardon power I love that
the executive the spirited part of our
government has the ability to do that
some presidents abuse at Bill Clinton
abused at Barack Obama certainly abused
it as well but I don't think Trump is
abusing it and I'm I would rather run
the risk of presidents pardoning too
many people then not have that ability
at all all right that is our show we've
got a lot more to get to but you know of
course we don't have time we run out of
time
every single week tune back in on Monday
in the mean to by the way I should
announce I'm gonna fly out next week to
Washington DC because senator Ted Cruz
and I will be doing a live verdict
podcast at CPAC this year so if you're
gonna be the seatback we hope to see you
there in the room if not you know go on
out there maybe we'll see you there and
I'll see you on the East Coast in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka Geneva
production assistant
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]